hi and welcome back to rapid fire
language journey today we're exploring
the question
how to learn two languages at the same
time and in this regard i have two
things that
it they're actually on the not to-do
list the first thing is do not
rotate meaning that if you want to learn
two languages at the same time make sure
that you learn
both of them every single day do not
learn one language one day and the other
language the
the following day or every two days or
every week you do
you know one cycle of a language and
then you do the other because this way
you're confusing your brain your brain
needs to know that these languages the
languages you're learning
are important so learning both of them
every single day
is actually quite important and the
second piece of advice is that if you're
learning
to start learning two languages from
scratch make sure that they're not very
similar
because otherwise you're gonna get
confused and the more similar these
languages are
the more confusion you're you're the
more confused you're going to get that's
it for today
thanks for watching over and out
you